[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas a pesar de que el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin aseguró
recientemente que no veía motivos para
continuar lanzando ataques masivos
contra Ucrania las embestidas con
misiles e incluso con drones kamikaze
han sacudido distintos puntos del suelo
ucraniano civiles han perdido la vida y
las autoridades han tenido que pedir a
la población reducir su consumo debido a
los graves daños que ha sufrido la red
eléctrica del país esto de cara un
invierno que se anuncia como
particularmente difícil estos ataques
también han golpeado ciudades alejadas
del frente de batalla como el vivo al
oeste de la nación aunque los apagones
han terminado por ahora las autoridades
afirman que sin embargo la red está muy
debilitada el siguiente es un informe de
nuestro corresponsal en el terreno
Gulliver crack
la electricidad ha vuelto a funcionar en
libif después de que los ataques con
misiles inutilizaran cuatro estaciones
secundarias eléctricas a principios de
esta semana la empresa local de
servicios públicos está orgullosa hemos
trabajado para activar todos los
sistemas de reserva a los habitantes de
la región del bif les suele gustar
quejarse cuando hay un corte de luz o
una caída de tensión Pero esta vez
reaccionaron con gran comprensión
incluso agradecieron a los ingenieros
eléctricos su trabajo pero al funcionar
con líneas de Reserva la red está
sometida a una gran presión se ha pedido
a los ciudadanos que reduzcan el consumo
para evitar los apagones en esta
ceremonia para celebrar el Día de las
fuerzas armadas en el centro del ibif
los que habían venido a mostrar su
gratitud al ejército dijeron que estaban
más dispuestos a apretarse el cinturón
solo hay una bombilla en la habitación
nos duchamos durante tres minutos como
máximo para que la Caldera no consuma
demasiada electricidad estamos haciendo
un esfuerzo estamos
a vivir sin luz sin lo que haga falta
con tal de poder vivir sin los rusos el
gobernador de la región del ibif junto
con el alcalde estuvo en la ceremonia
pero les preocupa que las buenas
intenciones de los ciudadanos no sean
suficientes y está haciendo planes de
contingencia para el racionamiento
puede bajar la temperatura y algunos a
residentes se encienden los calentadores
eléctricos la red eléctrica puede
romperse bajo la presión pero estos
ataques no hacen más que aumentar la
rabia de la gente y la conciencia de que
nos enfrentamos a un enemigo bajo cínico
y Bills
a pesar de la determinación de Ucrania
de no Rendirse Rusia continúa con su
campaña de ataques contra las
infraestructuras la masacre de bucha
constituye uno de los primeros crímenes
de guerra de Rusia en Ucrania según
Naciones Unidas han pasado más de seis
meses desde esta matanza y ahora los
supervivientes luchan por sobreponerse
para poder seguir adelante con sus vidas
nuestros corresponsales etel bonet y
Diego Ibarra visitaron la zona
es verdad no ha sacado a pasear a su
hijo Vladimir al cementerio habla de mí
le cuesta entender la muerte para
evitarle más dolor le ha contado que su
padre está dormido el 4 de marzo fue
alcanzado por una bala mortal de un
francotirador ruso cuando salió a
comprar pañales para hablador
no pude recoger el cadáver tuvimos que
irnos porque temía por Vladimir y tuve
que dejarle aquí solo el cuerpo del
marido desved lana y otros 14 civiles
permanecieron esta calle de bucha por un
mesentero ahora sus vecinos la han
renombrado el callejón de la muerte
tetania nos muestra las imágenes de
soldados rusos sacando a civiles de sus
casas Que consiguió grabar con su móvil
8 personas fueron ejecutadas detrás del
patio trasero de su vivienda
no es justo que tantas mujeres se quedan
sin marido que los niños se quedan sin
padre Solo quiero que los que cometieron
estos crímenes sean castigados
no es fácil lidiar con el dolor de la
muerte sobre todo si ha sido en
circunstancias trágicas
hemos trabajado juntos toda la vida a él
lo tomaron cautivo los rusos y a mí me
dejaron libre No superen nada más de él
Hasta que vi su tumba pero más difícil
es sobreponerse a la desaparición de un
ser querido Alexandra Lleva más de seis
meses sin saber nada de su padre Sigue
esperando cada día la llamada los
servicios para buscar los desaparecidos
durante la Guerra habiendo solo mi padre
nos pidió que nos fuéramos de aquí me
dijo este lugar va a ser horrible yo me
quedaré el 24 de marzo leí en facebook
que había desaparecido lo llamé varias
veces pero su teléfono estaba apagado
desde ese día aparecen mis sueños para
hablarme
las matanzas y desapariciones de cientos
de civiles en bucha y recientemente
emisión han causado profundas heridas
psicológicas entre la población Y si no
hay justicia si no hay rendición de
cuentas el trauma perseguirá a las
nuevas generaciones
en Nueva York continúa la batalla legal
por el porte de armas en un intento por
reducir el porte oculto de armamento y
también el crimen el alcalde ericadams
declaró a Time Square una de las zonas
más emblemáticas de la ciudad como libre
de armas sin embargo un juez Federal
derogó partes de la nueva normativa a
pedido de algunos ciudadanos que la
consideran inconstitucional el informe
es de nuestra corresponsal en la gran
manzana
John lleva una pistola desde principios
de los años 60
es una de las 76.200 personas con
licencia en el estado de Nueva York para
aportarla la demanda de armas se ha
disparado en el último mes a pesar de
que no es fácil caminar por la ciudad
armado
sí tengo que ir a la corte a recoger un
arma tengo que pensar por donde voy si
voy a pasar por algún colegio o algún
mercado de calle tengo que planear mi
ruta para así no violar las
restricciones en esas áreas
este es uno de los pocos lugares donde
puede moverse libremente con su arma
asegura que la nueva ley donde se
prohíbe el porte de armas en algunas
zonas públicas es una venganza de la
gobernadora de Nueva York a la decisión
de la Corte Suprema
has escuchado la expresión diente por
diente tú haces algo yo voy a hacer algo
así que cuando la Corte Suprema salió
con esa Norma el gobernador salió con
algo que oponía esa Pero hay excepciones
y Johnny es una de ellas un policía
retirado que puede llevar su pistola
encima Incluso en el famoso kilómetro
cero de la gran manzana
el policía que esté activo o fuera de
servicio o un policía retirado como soy
yo que me acabo de retirar carteles como
este marcan la zona libre de armas pero
son casi imperceptibles
entonces lo que te digo el criminal no
va a obedecer a esa señalización según
Johnny con esta nueva Norma que incluye
13 cuadras solo se castiga a quienes
tienen una licencia de armas un juez
bloqueó partes de esta nueva ley y ahora
la fiscal general de Nueva York ha
pelado el fallo las autoridades
defienden el equilibrio que es
asegurarse que la gente propietario
responsables de armas puedan ejecutar
sus derechos constitucionales pero al
mismo tiempo asegurarnos de que todo el
mundo es consciente de cuáles son las
reglas y también se sientan seguros la
batalla legal ha comenzado y en medio
están ellos propietarios de licencias
que solo les queda muy de cerca a las
nuevas normas
Como cada 16 de octubre se conmemoró el
Día Mundial de la Alimentación una fecha
promovida por la organización de
Naciones Unidas para la alimentación y
la agricultura FAO dedicada a generar
conciencia con el objetivo de disminuir
el hambre en el mundo un hombre que
todavía desafortunadamente pasan
millones de personas sin embargo en
países más ricos como Francia se enfocan
en evitar el desperdicio de alimentos
enseñándole a los jóvenes la importancia
del buen comer veamos el informe que ha
preparado nuestra periodista Erika
olavarría
vienen directamente de la huerta pero la
gente no quería comprarlas porque tienen
algunas manchas pero desde que las abres
la belleza está en el interior
exactamente la belleza está en el
interior
Adrián lanza el desafío a los alumnos de
este colegio de París demostrar que
pueden hacer una buena pizza con estas
verduras que no tienen buen aspecto
mezclando harinas que quedaron de un
taller de cocina pasado y con restos de
queso
y los jóvenes de 13 años logran con
creces el objetivo la alimentación cero
desperdicio es uno de los principales
temas de la escuela comestible que
enseña de manera lúdica a niños y
adolescentes la importancia de comer
bien
en Francia un cuarto de personas pasa
hambre así que solo por cuestiones
humanas aprender a no tirar es
importante también por ecología
producimos demasiado contaminamos y son
energías y petróleo que liberamos y por
economía También es importante poder
cocinar gastando
desperdicios alimentarios hay en cada
hogar pero a mayor escala también en los
supermercados este pequeño ubicado en el
distrito 14 retira de las estanterías
varios kilos por semana
aunque han llegado a la fecha
recomendada para el consumo marcada en
el paquete la ley permite su ingesta
hasta tres meses después
una parte importante de esos alimentos
los recupera jafar que trabaja para
Fénix una empresa solidaria de utilidad
social
lo que recolecta luego lo distribuye a
alguna asociación local
como este supermercado solidario del
distrito 14
la sociedad
la asociación la asociación es muy
importante para nuestra asociación
porque nos trae productos frescos que no
podemos comprar con o sin crisis
económica tenemos un cierto número de
familias que ayudar y estamos llenos
Aunque tenemos cada vez más demandas
haciendo estas donaciones el
supermercado desgrava impuestos y se
ahorra dinero al no ocuparse de desechar
lo que no pudo vender negocio redondo
según Fénix que ya ha metido en este
círculo virtuoso a 500 supermercados
queremos agradecer a seis manos por
prestarnos sus instalaciones para la
grabación de este programa ya ustedes
también Muchas gracias por seguir un
nuevo episodio de corresponsales nos
damos cita la próxima semana siga con
más información en francés 24 y France
24.com